for nine minutes on the upper deck of a
London bus Milania and girlfriend Chris
were subjected to sexual gestures
comments and had coins thrown at them by
a group of teenage boys until it became
too much
later bloodied and in shock a photo of
the couple quickly went viral I think it
was really striking just how far and
wide that picture when it was a real
wake-up call for people across the
country who I think probably had thought
the LGBT lives were much easier now it
isn't hard to find similar stories
Thomas Johnson had been coming home from
a wedding with his sister when he was
harassed by a couple at a train station
he'd been talking on the phone when they
picked on him making comments imitating
my voice it was like a school playground
my sister step-step stood back her
boyfriend then saw opportunity as the
trains train doors about to closed and
try and hit me I cannot step back he
knocked my glasses off as I've gone to
pick them up it was like a slow-motion I
knew my face shaking with fear
Thomas followed them onto the train and
filmed this as evidence my hours it was
shared 2,000 times like 3,000 times it
just went crazy they had seen that he
had taken the picture one of my pictures
from my facebook post about the attack
and update his profile picture Facebook
almost like he's proud that he did it
proud of the tag taunting me it was
again I was really a humiliation again
figures suggest while more incidents are
being reported to police fewer people
are being prosecuted for homophobic hate
crimes I think both the Crown
Prosecution Service the corpse and the
police they're doing the best they can
but there's this deluge of other crime
it's not good enough to say we know you
have thicker skin
so much anguish knew the teenagers who
admitted harassing Milania and Chris
were only 15 16 and 17 while the image
from that night was shocking it exposed
how LGBT discrimination is alive and
well and how the fight for equality is
far from over
Katie Spencer Sky News